- Was denkst du, Selma?
- Ich weiß es nicht.
Eigentlich muss ich glücklich sein.
Wir können jetzt in Deutschland
bleiben, aber …
- Das ist nicht deine Heimat.
- Doch. Es ist eine andere …
eine neue Heimat.
Ich finde Deutschland schön.
- Aber Deutschland ist anders als
die alte Heimat, als Syrien, oder?
- Ja. Das Essen ist anders,
das Wetter, die Sprache.
Und die Menschen auch.
Alles ist anders.
- Habt ihr in Syrien denn auch
Frühling, Sommer, Herbst und Winter
wie in Deutschland?
- Ja, wir haben auch Jahreszeiten.
Aber im Winter ist es nicht so kalt.
- Und das Essen?
- Wir essen viel Fleisch.
Bei uns gibt es nicht viele Vegetarier.
Aber vor allem gibt es in Syrien nicht
so viele Regeln wie in Deutschland.
Und es gibt viel mehr Leben auf
der Straße, besonders am Abend.
Die Läden sind länger geöffnet,
die Menschen sind draußen.
Alles ist ein bisschen
spontaner und lockerer.
Ja, eigentlich ist fast alles anders.
Aber ich finde,
die Menschen hier in Deutschland
sind genauso nett
wie die Menschen in Syrien.